[Music]
john
we have a ton millions
of young people 18 to 25 years old
now tuning into this program with
youtube and some of the other
technologies we're using to deliver the
program
um it's become wildly popular in that
age group half the calls i get these
days are from 25 years old and under
um and regardless of your age
whether you're of that age group or
you're 35 or you're 45
we have a tendency
i do it too
to overload our lives
that guy in the last call he had a lot
of stressors you were pointing out
and you know any one of those things
would have been a tough thing
when you start stacking things five deep
and they were all a choice
um the correlation between that
and uh damage to your personal
self damage to your finances damage to
your career damage to your relationships
is really really high and it it's
um kind of a superman syndrome
um my wife um
she'll say uh you don't need to do that
that's jesus's job
stop being the messiah hmm you can't you
can't do everything you can't be
everywhere
you can't do all this you're stacking
this too thick
that's jesus's job only he can do that
you're taking responsibility for things
you can't fix you're taking
responsibility for
too many things you can fix and it's
getting too thick and
the uh the camel's back is gonna pop
with one more straw
there there seems to be a um a busyness
an efficiency uh maybe it's maybe it's
the iphone culture
well we have we have a cultural
pathology if you will like a
a psychological issue which is you solve
things by
adding two you solve things by
getting another planner going to get
more candles having a warm bath yoga and
we never think that i can solve things
by taking things away by stopping things
that's number one number two we have a
cultural addiction to busyness
that is our bread and butter right if
you do
heroin you do cocaine they'll put you in
a rehab program or put you in jail
if you are addicted to busyness and it's
the same chemicals
addicted to busyness we'll give you a
million dollars we'll give you a
doctorate degree
we will applaud you it you're we're
running from the same stuff
we're trying to prove that we're worth
something by achieving we're trying to
trying to prove something by how much we
can get done
and show show and man i dave whenever i
find myself stacking things on top on
top on top
usually i've got a friend or two that
will call me and say
i don't know what you're running from
brother but you got to stop and take
inventory
well that was kind of our well we were
the friend for that last guy
said there's too much stack too hey
there's two what do you do and he's
trying to solve this problem by doing
this and then trying to solve that one
by doing that
and suddenly he's a couple hundred
thousand dollars in the hole making zero
money living in his parents house
and indefinitely right right and it does
the math doesn't add up
the psychological and spiritual math and
the the calculator math
none of it adds up and you just gotta
sometimes start from ground zero
some of it does come from uh
even a generation before mine and i'm
old yeah it just
took longer to solve problems which
provided for space
and wisdom and margin margin right but
now
if you want anything you pick up this
little square thing with a glass on the
front and you tap it three times and
stuff shows up at your
door right like freaking santa claus is
alive 24
7. that's exactly right donner and
blitzen work
all the time all the time we name him
jeff and bezos right
[Laughter]
you know and it's just yeah uh and now
it's not good enough that it comes in
two days has to come
same day right you know and our
efficiency
our productivity has gone through the
roof and our piece has
not increased it's in fact it's
decreasing right you know you would
think
that if you got better at stuff it was
easier to do things
that you could chill a little bit and
your piece would increase
um and if you don't leave that emotional
margin your adrenal
glands get burned and fried and other
stuff
starts to fall apart and you really
can't function that's when you get into
the diseases of despair right the organ
disease
failures and the suicides and the
addictions
we're living we've got more than we've
ever had and we are living shorter
harder lives because we just stay
constantly revved we put our foot on
that gas stave and we never take it off
and sometimes he may this young man that
we just talked to he may find himself in
the exact same
position but when i feel like i'm on a
house of cards and it's teetering off
it's best to stop get somebody i trust
in this case his fiancee
go sit somewhere and just start from the
floor up say what do we have to do
this is that second or third call today
we've had where people feel trapped in
this either or decision
and none of the and neither decision was
good no and neither decision isn't
either or right
yeah and we just shove ourselves into
these boxes no
it's not um it's not filling out a
registration for a new app
absolutely no man yeah
uh in other words if you're making
decisions number one you need to leave
yourself some margin
some wiggle room emotionally spiritually
financially
relationally or you're going to
negatively impact the other things
enough that it offsets any positive you
did with the decision
and you have to be prepared when you
have margin dave
it's hard to be by yourself it is hard
to be
i spent a few days out in the woods by
myself this past week over thanksgiving
man i got bored i got uncomfortable
i hadn't i had time to think thoughts i
hadn't thought in a long time i had time
to write stuff down i mean it was
uncomfortable right you got to practice
being by yourself
um but yeah i don't even have to
practice that as much i just need to
practice
not trying to solve all the problems
in 20 minutes that's right not trying to
stack it
so layered that there is just every
ounce is squeezed out because um
one flat tire and the whole the whole
shebang goes out yeah right yeah
there's too much wood on the truck i
mean when i used to cut wood
sold firewood when i was in college we
filled that truck up and it beat like
you know the front tires are almost
coming off the ground
the thing's just dragging on the tires
and you know we've completely filled it
up
but i mean you know you got the shocks
are strained the tires are strained the
engine is strained the bed itself is
strained the cattle gates on the side
holding the wood and we're strained
everything one of those variables blows
the whole thing is going to look like a
cartoon instead of just making two trips
yeah right just make two trips
i tell my little boy that all the time
well and then and now i gotta go the car
in a few minutes and i
should take two trips with all the crap
i gotta carry the car instead i'm gonna
have
pile it all up i'll be dropping stuff on
the way the car it's the same thing
right it's the same thing and my point
of bringing this up is not
him not the caller because he's not
doing anything wrong he's a sharp young
guy
yeah and they're going to do fine
they'll be all right but the point is
that we can all take a lesson from
that people who become wealthy
are always the tortoise they're never
the hair
they leave room for the plod
along rather than the rush the tortoise
always wins
every time i read the book right ugly
little sucker
every time every time this is the dave
ramsey show